[Music]
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
Scripps memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johan goodberg science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
so an activist seems to me to be someone
who hypothetically advocates for the
oppressed which is already a moral
danger it's because like what the hell
made you advocate for the oppressed did
they elect you as why are you the
spokesman and what gives you that moral
virtue so you know those are major
questions but also
it it comes with it this temptation
because if you're an activist you're
almost always against something you're
always identifying the problem with the
world
uh as being something that some other
person who isn't good like you is doing
and then what we do is we present young
people in high school and in University
with the notion that well there's if you
really care about the world there's
nothing more honorable than you could do
that you could possibly do than to
become an activist and I really kind of
think that in some sense there are
almost no lower calling than activist I
think it's within our nature especially
as young people to get obsessed with
this idea of radical transformation and
this lure of of transformation and uh it
wasn't until I met Dave Rubin who I'm
sure you're familiar with and he he put
out this quote of you know when I was on
this side of things I was trying to
control the world now that I'm out of it
I'm trying to understand the world and
that's something that a lot of young
people are not obsessed with they don't
want to understand the world and their
place with it within it they feel a
sense of discomfort and they want to
attribute that sense of discomfort to
something else and find what is a common
enemy and it's really easy to find a
common enemy if you listen to anybody
who is obsessed with this with this woke
ideology
[Music]
hello everyone on YouTube and It's
associated platforms and podcasts I'm
talking today to amla epinobi she was a
radical leftist leftist activist as a
young person and
um has undergone quite a political and
philosophical transformation in recent
years and so we're going to talk to her
about that and about her work with
prageru today
she's an American YouTube commentator as
I said working under the prageru brand
her Channel Unapologetic has amassed
over half a million subscribers in a
very short time by the way spearheaded
initially by her story her mother is a
left-wing pundit who works on
professional fundraising Amela grew up
fully believing in leftist ideology
before having a radical change in
thought recognizing the hate coming from
those around her who were tolerant she
made a hard choice to confront her
bosses in a leftist organization on
these thoughts and was not only shut
down but belittled by being told you
don't even realize how oppressed you are
and this was the final straw from here
she left her workplace dived into her
own education on the founding fathers
and the institutions as they were
originally designed in America and how
social media Works using these new
skills in tandem she launched a
conservative Tick-Tock channel of all
things and found herself going viral
regularly it wasn't long after she
joined prageru as the host of her own
show
raised in a far-left activist household
22 year old Amela epinobi was once a
student organizer for the left
unanswered questions and a search for
the truth led her to a complete
ideological transformation
passionately sharing her new
conservative values online Amala became
a viral social media sensation she is
now the host of prageru's popular show
Unapologetic with Amela she inspires
millions of young people every day to
discover the truth defend their values
and Lead Better Lives I met her at a
prageru Gala about a month ago it's
December 2022 at the moment so a month
ago would have put us in November I
think that's about right and uh
I was there talking to Dennis Prager and
she
uh had a speech after me and it was
really quite compelling and I thought it
would be very interesting to talk to
umla on my podcast as a consequence um
she's quite young she's made a bit of a
splash online uh maybe more than a bit
and so when I listened to her talk I
thought well here's someone who seems to
have a clue and who's probably going
somewhere so let's find out exactly who
she is and so that's the plan today I
want to get to know her a little bit and
to walk all of you through it so let's
start with what you're doing now you're
working for prageru and that's a very
evil thing to do as you know full well
and so I'm quite curious about how you
how that came about and how old are you
I'm 22 at the moment right okay okay
okay so you're not you're not a pop
you're just but you're out of that
you're out of pop hood a little bit
anyways yeah so okay how did you how did
it come to be how did you come to start
doing uh videos for Prager tell me
exactly what you're doing at prageru
sure yeah so at the moment I my job
titles prageru personality uh which I
guess a student but I have some sort of
Personality
um and and what that involves now is I
do podcasting and social media content
and just talk about cultural issues
today's politics and news from a young
person's perspective and particularly a
young conservative leaning perspective
so that's what I do now and Prager you
found me because I started making videos
on the internet about a journey that I
had from being what I consider to be a
really radical leftist to a now sort of
right-of-center person
right right so you're a conservative
personality that that those two words
haven't gone together that well during
the entire span of my life so that's
kind of a funny thing all together and
so how often are you making how often
are you making videos for Prager
every single day we put out content so
uh we're constantly staying on our toes
and keeping up with everything that's
going on in the world and uh that that's
that's our our daily life right now is
just looking at what's happening looking
at the conversations that people are
having and what's trending and then
hopefully giving a reasonable
perspective on it
right so how much how much content are
you producing every day
uh at least I would say three short form
videos that are about 60 seconds long as
well as one long form video that will be
anywhere from 15 minutes to an hour and
then we do a live podcast on Mondays
Wednesdays and Fridays that goes for
about an hour
oh yeah okay okay and on the the short
form so those are about 60 seconds long
yep yep we'll pick a trending topic or a
new story and then just give you a
60-second rundown of what's Happening as
well as a little bit of opinion on it
right and so what platforms are you
using for the short forms
everything we're on Instagram Twitter
YouTube Facebook you name it we're there
are you on tick tock
yes Tick Tock I have an up and down
relationship with Tick Tock as I get
banned probably every other week for the
content that I put out congratulations
being banned by the Chinese Communists
is always a really good thing yeah yeah
we should be running a favor in Spades
yes I agree yes yes definitely and so
where where do you have the biggest
following
my biggest following is now on on
YouTube my my Tick Tock account is
currently banned that would have been my
biggest following at about
640k I believe but now we've we've
reached that on YouTube
oh well congratulations and how fast are
you growing on YouTube
well we started our Channel I want to
say about in April of this year so
that's how how quickly it's been about
been about nine months
oh and you said you were making videos
before Prager picked you up and what
what platforms were you using for those
videos when did you start doing that
I started out on Tick Tock of all
platforms and I want to say I started
there at the end of 2019 and I in a
matter of months managed to amass a few
hundred thousand followers because I
think I was speaking to a perspective
that people weren't used to on the
platform and I have a particular look
being a biracial female I think that's
not to be ignored in it having a factor
in Me growing so quickly on these
platforms but Tick Tock is where things
really started to take off
men is it time to stop mindless
scrolling time to finally gain that
higher quality of life you know you're
missing out on if this sounds familiar
then on January 9th join thousands of
men all over the world to embark on a
90-day journey together in search of a
better life
it's called Exodus 90 and it was built
to help men enjoy the freedom of
becoming who they were truly made to be
Exodus 90 guides you in removing the
attachments that are holding you back
from a better life and it actually works
independent research shows that Exodus
90 men report considerable shifts after
the first 90 days including stronger
satisfaction rates in their marriages
more meaningful prayer lives and
dramatic decreases in time spent on
their phones
for the past seven years Exodus has
helped more than 60 thousand men build a
road map for living with virtue in a
culture that offers far too many paths
to self-destruction
is it time for your Exodus we start
January 9th find resources to prepare
for Exodus at exodus90.com Jordan that's
exodus90.com Jordan
yeah so what do you think you were doing
that
made what you were saying relevant vital
to people I mean you you pointed to a
couple of things hey your use and your
biracial status and I suppose that the
combination of those two things and the
fact that you were offering a counter
narrative but that doesn't seem to me to
be enough like you when you see that
kind of explosive growth across multiple
platforms you you have to think that
you've you're saying something in the
right way for the moment and so what is
it about what you're doing that is
attracting attention is it mostly
positive attention are you getting a lot
of are you getting a lot of trouble
and and yeah so that would also be in
your personal life as well as your own
life online life because those aren't
the same thing so what are you doing
right
what am I doing right that's a big
question uh you know when I started out
on the platform it was just a leisurely
thing I unfortunately a downloaded Tick
Tock is a form of entertainment and
started scrolling through this curated
for you page which of course takes in
your demographics and realizes somewhat
of who you are as a person and then
feeds you videos that they think you'll
like and the videos that I was being fed
were just a lot of leftist radical
ideology really reducing me down to my
gender my race talking about how pivotal
it was that I was to be a member of the
feminist movement or of black lives
matter and I saw that and and thought
wow it's very interesting that this app
took in my demographics and this is what
it fed me I wonder if there's anybody
saying anything contrary to this so one
day I took out my phone and I filmed a
video talking about how I used to be a
former leftist and now I'm on the other
side of things and and that part of me
sort of died off but spoke to it a
little bit and my videos started taking
off purely due to hatred people were
very upset at me espousing these views
and I got every single name you can
think of for what I was doing and then
with oh that's fine
yeah yeah it was it was something that I
expected by virtue of having been on
that side of things already I knew what
I was going to walk into with that but
with that came just this wave of support
of people seeing the hate that I was
getting and wanting to to be a part of
of the the counter Narrative of that
right well that's interesting because
it's it's certainly been the case that
in respect to my rise to notoriety let's
say the most vitriolic attacks have been
the ones that have done me the most good
certainly and that's pretty weird you
know it isn't necessarily how you look
at life but the first video that really
went viral in relationship to my
political activity I put up a couple of
videos criticizing the University of
Toronto's idiot HR policies you know
predicated on diversity inclusivity and
equity and they're half begotten dimwit
interpretation of of human psychological
functioning the idea that you could use
um explicit anti-racist training to
overcome implicit racist bias which is
like the most Preposterous thing ever
from a psychological perspective
criticized that in this compelled speech
law in Canada then some activists
cornered me I'd been speaking at a at a
free speech rally which I didn't arrange
by the way and uh I got a lot of trouble
there a lot of white noise generation a
lot of almost violent pushback from the
hypothetical radical left and then a
bunch of activists cornered me on the
way in to my building my office building
and they filmed it
the encounter talking about all the
Nazis that were at My Free Speech rally
and first of all
I don't know what it's like in the
United States at the moment although
I've been there quite a bit there aren't
any Nazis in Canada that's just not a
Canada thing I don't know anyone who
knows anyone who's ever met anyone who
claims to be a Nazi like it's just not
an issue and so that was completely
Preposterous anyways they filmed this
encounter you know
uh claiming that I was attracting all
sorts of
demented right Wingers and
that went viral
the idea was to
damage my reputation but exactly the
opposite happened and then I I've had a
number of encounters with journalists
that have been
definitely the journalists were just
they're real vipers you know they're the
sort of people
in fact one of them eventually admitted
that this is what she was doing this was
Nelly bows Bulls who used to work for
the New York Times she actually wrote an
apology a public apology although not
specifically to me saying that as in New
York Times journalist she made her
career by going out to purposefully
destroy people
and so talking to journalists like that
it's really like it's like walking
through a a nest of vipers because
the people who do that sort of thing ask
their questions in a way that is
designed to make you say something that
will be fatal to your reputation
permanently so that their status can be
elevated as the person that outed you
but interestingly enough just to wrap
this story up is every time that's
happened
although it made things shaky for a
couple of weeks or a couple of months
afterwards the positive consequences
have eventually been far greater than
the negative consequences and so that
being attacked you know that can be a
well first of all it forces to get your
arguments in line
but it also can be a real well as you
said you know your your sense is that
had you not been subject to all that
abuse
you probably wouldn't have grown as
quickly
yeah all of the the pivotal moments in
what has been a very very short career
so far have been when people have come
at me with hatred and vitriol and
painted this really evil of pic evil
picture of me and then people who want
to believe that and want to see what I
have to say in order to throw hate at me
end up finding my message and eventually
having this reaction of wow she's really
not that bad uh because I understand the
people that I speak out against I come
forward and say Here's why you believe
what you believe and with everything
you're seeing right now I completely
understand it because I was there I'm
not going to shout at you about how
you're stupid or brainwashed because you
know that was me four years ago even so
I try to approach all the conversations
I have with that perspective so people
are expecting to meet this really evil
Bulldog abrasive individual and then
they find my videos and go oh it's not
at all what what these hate comments
were saying it's totally different yeah
well so when this first viral video went
and out I already had about 150 hours of
YouTube content up because I posted a
lot of my lectures because I was playing
around with YouTube at that point trying
to figure out how useful it was as a
broad communication platform and so what
happened again parallels your experience
was people went to check out my YouTube
video because they were assuming that I
was you know foaming at the mouth and
found out that well this is actually
literally the case I probably have 200
hours of lectures up might be more than
that now and the people who've been
interested say in mischaracterizing me
and also in taking me out haven't been
able to find in all of those hours one
single statement that even taken out of
context would indicate that you know I
have any of the nefarious Notions or
motivations that have been described to
me and so what's so interesting about
that it's really it's really powerful in
a paradoxical way because people go
looking
for you let's say assuming that you're
some kind of Junior monster so not only
do they find out that's not true
they found out they find out that the
opposite is true
and so then they find out that you're
being pilloried not by people not only
by people who are lying and who are
corrupt and malevolent because of their
lies but they're doing something worse
than lying because you know if you're a
skillful liar
you tell a lie that's very close to the
truth right because it can kind of slip
by but there are anti-truths which are
different than lies and an anti-truth is
something that couldn't be farther away
from the truth if you tried to make it
farther away and so you had the benefit
of that is that you were pilloried by
people who were telling anti-truths
about you and then people come and see
oh my God she's nothing like I was led
to believe and then that starts to raise
serious doubts in the back of their mind
it's like just what the hell is going on
here because this isn't just a lie this
is this is the complete opposite of
reality itself
so that's very interesting too it's very
interesting to watch that emerge all
right so you started working on Tick
Tock and you started to get a lot of
hatred and then a lot of attention what
happened after tick tock
within a matter of months I received a
message on my Instagram from somebody
working here at prageru and they said
you know we've seen your videos and
we're we're very interested in you
coming out here and telling your story
is it possible that we could get you on
a call and I got on a call and told my
story over the matter of a couple of
minutes and they said let's fly you out
to Los Angeles and we want you to do a
video for a series we have called
stories of us where you sit for an hour
you tell us your story and we will chop
that up and put that out to the internet
and I got here I met with many of the
higher ups who were working here and on
the second day of my trip was offered a
job and they said would you like to come
here and and do this full-time start
making your videos and putting them out
on social media and we'll support you
and resource that for you and at the
time that had really not crossed my mind
I was working at a medical clinic as a
tech and had every intention of
continuing my school and going into
nursing and Midwifery so I thought about
it for a second and thought you know
this is a pretty important opportunity
that I get and that it's just sitting at
my feet right now and I'd be pretty dumb
to not take them up on it so I dropped
everything and moved out to LA within a
matter of weeks
yeah well good for you I mean yeah when
opportunity comes knocking like that
then you know it's sensible to take
advantage of the situation in the in the
most positive possible way what's it
been like working with the Prager crew
oh it's been great I think the the best
thing about working here is that I have
freedom to really talk about whatever I
want to talk about on any given day and
I think it's very rare to have a job
that supports you in that sense so I
really wake up every day and get to look
at things that I'm passionate about
speaking about and then bring that to
the Forefront for for other people to
hear there's certainly a lot of pressure
that comes with it as I'm sure you feel
as well you you want to be on the right
side of things you want to speak to
things that are are true and that can be
difficult because we make mistakes and
sometimes we're wrong and I'm very young
to be doing this so that's something
that stays on my brain a lot but but
other than that it's it's a it's a
really great job how do you keep your
ego under control
because I I know how fallible I am as a
human being I think that's what keeps me
uh in in control and I try to stay hyper
aware of my my shortcomings and my
blinders and I really approach things
with the sense that I could be wrong
about anything I'm saying on on any
given day and I want to have that sort
of care for myself so I'll give that
care to other people and it really keeps
me humble because there's many times
where I'm wrong or I'll come at a
subject matter feeling super defensive
about it or needing something to be
right and I don't realize that until far
later so I try to keep that in mind
whenever I'm doing anything
start the new year off right with Black
Rifle coffee
Black Rifle has all the best Brewing
gear thermosis mugs and apparel designed
for folks who love country and coffee
Black Rifle sources the most exotic
roast from around the globe all coffee
is roasted here in the U.S by
veteran-led teams of coffee experts
every purchase you make with Black Rifle
helps support veteran and first
responder causes go to
blackriflecoffee.com and use promo code
Jordan for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear and
apparel or join the Black Rifle coffee
club for automatic deliveries to your
door on your schedule
save 10 with promo code Jordan that's
black riflecoffee.com promo code Jordan
Black Rifle coffee supporting veterans
and America's coffee
[Music]
yeah well it hasn't been this long that
long since you've done a an uh 180 on
your belief system and so that's also
got to be kind of Paramount in your mind
let's talk about that a little bit so
um when I was a kid 14. I worked with a
woman named Sandy nortley and her
husband Grant notley and Grant was the
member of the legislative assembly for
my home constituency my riding in
Fairview in and uh he was the only
opposition member in the entire Alberta
Parliament essentially
and he was a socialist the entire
Province was conservative except for him
he was a socialist now the reason he was
elected in that writing wasn't because
he was a socialist in fact he was
elected I would say in spite of the fact
that he was a socialist he was actually
a good man and everybody knew that and
trusted him and so I worked for the NDP
that new Democratic party party for
about three years and uh
I was a good friend of his wife she was
the librarian at our local junior high
school and she introduced me to Serious
literature and uh I really liked her she
was a real good Mentor kind of an
eccentric New England woman quite well
educated by the standards of the little
town that I grew up in and so she
pointed me to Huxley and Orwell and soul
schnitzen and I Ian Rand as well to her
credit because of course Rand is no
socialist and uh
and then you know because I had access
to her and her husband and her husband
Grant was the leader of the Socialists
in Alberta he had access to premiers of
Alberta provinces and the national
leader of the NDP and over about a
three-year period I got to be a fly on
the wall in many meetings between senior
labor leaders and Senior socialist
leaders is this kind of Fabian socialism
that's got a British twist it isn't
really derived from the same say school
of thought that the Communists were
derived from and uh
I stopped working for them when I was
about 17 for reasons that I'll go into
but but I got to say a few things about
the Socialists of that time first of all
most of them had been labor leaders
you know so a lot of them were working
class guys mostly guys not all mostly
who and this was the leaders who had
worked themselves up the working class
hierarchy and then had adopted political
responsibilities one form or another and
most of those guys when I listen to them
I actually had a fair bit of respect for
them and admired them I actually thought
that
they were genuinely doing their best to
to put forward the interests of the
working class and at that time the
conservative party in Canada was pretty
much middle class upper middle class
guys in three-piece suits you know
Banker types it was clear the
conservative party was a voice of the
corporate world and then the Liberals
who were genuine Centrist liberals sort
of played both ends against the middle
and they did that quite successfully so
everybody knew where the political
parties stood in some real sense they
were different and the Socialists did
advocate for the working class but even
then you know I used to go to the party
conventions
and uh there were a lot of activists
there
and I didn't like the activists at all
they really made me nervous I thought
and then I read George Orwell and George
Orwell talked about socialist activists
back in the 1930s in the UK what did he
call them Tweed wearing leather patch
jacket champagne socialists like what
the hell do you guys have to do with the
poor announcer was nothing you don't
love the poor you just hate the rich
now the leaders I saw they like they
liked the working class you know they
were advocating on their behalf but
these activist types they were motivated
by pretty much nothing but resentment
and that really graded on me and I
stopped well I stopped working in
anything that was political well pretty
much from that point onward so
I think it's really easy for young
people
to be attracted to leftist ideas because
first of all young people are looking
for a cause and second
without much reflection it seems obvious
that
we should be advocating for the
oppressed
and then of course the leftists always
say that that's what they're doing
and so
given that your first moral impulse
might be to Advocate on the part of the
disaffected then it seems appropriate
that if you were attempting to be moral
that you would gravitate towards those
who claim to be speaking for the
dispossessed the question is are they
really speaking for them so why do you
think now you also have said and you
need to explain this to people that your
mother it was and is a left-wing uh
political activist
but so you have that reason for having
been hooked into the ideology let's say
do you want to expand on that a little
bit let's walk through your biography a
bit here and talk about the
philosophical reasons you were attracted
to it and also the personal reasons that
this particular idiom sure
yeah absolutely so I was raised by a
single mother for much of my life my
parents divorced when I was around six
years old so my mom took care of me and
and two siblings and through her single
motherhood really I was super involved
with her work if we got a day off school
we were gonna go to work with Mom and I
was going to see exactly what she was
doing and what she was doing was
fundraising for a left-leaning
organization out in Orlando Florida so
that was her day in and day out she's
politically quite obsessed with
virtually everything that's going on in
today's day and age so I would go to
work with my mom and she would give me
markers to write on posters little did I
know those posters were going to be used
in protests that they were staging in
the city so very deeply entrenched in
that from a really young age and my mom
happens to be white which I don't find
to be particularly important but it is
important in that she taught me from a
really young age that because I was
biracial life my be a little bit harder
for me living in this country due to its
history and how that history is
reflected in the present so I think more
so than than doing good for the world I
was attached to this sense of victimhood
and I thought that it was really pivotal
to my identity so I was a really angry
young person I was getting in arguments
all the time with kids who knew nothing
about politics about political issues
and I grew up in a very small rural
conservative town so it arguments were
ripe for the picking with anybody I I
chose and
anger was the first thing that I think
got me attached to the movement but then
it was going to my mother's work and
like you said there was a lot of working
class people involved during the
hurricanes in Florida they would do food
Banking and and give out food to the
needy so it was a lot of very radical
policy prescription mixed in with pretty
pragmatic helping of of people who
happen to be lower income and living in
lower income communities so I think I
just got my wires crossed in thinking
that because we were doing good on a
small scale that meant that these
radical prescriptions that we were
calling for were also good
yeah well that's a critical point you
know because
okay so let's delve into that a little
bit and think it through so
look one of the it's definitely the case
that one of the sources of sophisticated
morality is compassion
right although we're we're making a big
mistake in the modern world by elevating
compassion to the what would you call a
status of unique virtue because there's
lots of other
more primordial building blocks of
virtue that are as important as
compassion so for example everyone's
enjoined now
um to not be judgmental and that really
means to be casually dismissive and I do
think casually dismissive is a mistake
but judgmental discriminating that's not
a mistake that's a virtue because to be
judgmental and to be discriminating
means that you you dispense with what
isn't worthy and you pursue with with
you pursue what is
what is worthy and truthful is a virtue
and
um
well we can start with that
um sensitive to beauty is a virtue
all of those things have to be melded
into higher order virtues but compassion
leaps out to dominate and so it's it's
easy to assume that if you're motivated
by something like a reflexive compassion
that everything you think and want is
therefore both good practical necessary
and morally justifiable worse than that
and that this might be the most toxic
element of it is that if you believe
that you're motivated by compassion and
compassion is the highest virtue and
then you run into anyone who opposes
your views then it's super easy to
demonize them and that that's also a
huge problem now I think that's rooted
to some degree in the Neurology of
maternal compassion so think about it
this way you know when you're a mother
of a young infant
you should be 100 compassionate so let's
say zero to six months because the
infant is completely helpless it can't
move
so in in an infant can't be autonomous
at all before
that young person is capable of
voluntary movement right so there's just
no autonomy without voluntary movement
so till children can crawl they're
completely dependent on their mother and
what that means is their mother has to
be a hundred percent compassionate
because everything the child wants when
it's in that infantile stage has to be
dealt with
with no argument one hundred percent of
the time
and so and and more than that
so because the child is so vulnerable
the cost of labeling something as a
predator that isn't a predator is very
low
but the cost of labeling something that
is a predator not a predator is very
high and so along with that overarching
compassion Comes This proclivity to
overlabel things as predatory and that's
protective but it it does not scale well
into the political landscape I don't
think that we can scale an ethos of
compassion I don't think you can
actually scale it beyond the family Ben
Shapiro I was talking to him about this
recently and he said something quite
witty which was that well at home he's a
communist
right with his kids well it's it's from
each according to their ability to each
according to their need sure and and and
that's right because with your children
you're trying to keep things Equitable
in terms of outcome even and you are
calling on them to deliver what they can
and you provide to them what they need
and so and then it's an open question
especially if you're not particularly
mature in your thinking it's an open
question well why can't we use exactly
those principles to govern well large
corporations or educational institutions
or the world as a totality and the
answer to that seems to me to be
something like the fundamental
the most fundamental feminine ethos does
not scale it's a local ethos it's for
infants and family members fundamentally
and I think that's associated on the
personality front with the distinction
between agreeableness and
conscientiousness
so agreeableness is the compassionate
temperamental
dimension
and women are more agreeable than men
quite reliably although the difference
isn't huge it's big at the extremes but
it's not huge it's not particularly
large in the middle if you pick a random
man and a random woman out of the
population and you ask which one was
more compassionate if you pick the woman
you'd be right sixty percent of the time
but you'd be wrong 40 so you can see
that there's still a lot of overlap but
agreeableness does not predict success
in the broader world
conscientiousness does and
conscientiousness is a much colder
virtue right it seemed it because a
conscientious person will call you out
on your misbehavior even if it hurts
your feelings let's say and a
conscientious person is someone who will
forestall immediate pleasure or even
undergo a certain amount of of immediate
discomfort for a longer term gain
and our our our
well-functioning institutions seems to
seem to be predicated on an ethic of
conscientiousness and not an ethic of
compassion and I don't think we've got
that straightened out at all like we
certainly don't communicate that idea to
young people say look there's a place
for compassion but it's the local and
it's the local and infantile in some
sense and then that brings up another
question you know and nobody's been able
to have a serious discussion about this
is women have really entered the
political sphere on mass in the last 60
years let's say yep I don't think
anybody would dispute that particular
idea and we know there's all sorts of
masculine political pathologies right
maybe uh uh overt proclivity towards a
kind of aggressive narcissism that might
result in the creation of stupid Wars
for egotistical reasons that might be an
expression of masculine Psychopathology
on the political front but no one we
haven't had a serious discussion at all
about feminine Psychopathology on the
political front and I think we miss a
whole it's I've been trying to formulate
it as something like narcissism of
compassion you know the idea that just
because you're feeling maternal that
your love can envelop the whole world
and now by Fiat all your political
opinions are correct merely because you
know you feel sorry for kittens
so I'm not making light of that right
well you get that exactly that that that
that that that sort of that reflexive
compassion is not a moral virtue and the
reason for that is that moral virtues
are a lot more sophisticated Okay so
we've gone over some of the ideas why
young people might be attracted to the
compassionate ideal now you used to go
to work with your mom you were pulled
into this she had
do you
okay and then so when did the crack
start to show and you were getting in a
lot of arguments that's interesting too
as an activist type because that's a
weird Loop to be in too because your
mother was teaching you according to
your own testimony let's say
to view yourself as a victim for let's
say for your racial status even though
she was white herself and that also
compelled you to argue with people and
my suspicions are that why wouldn't that
reinforce your feeling of alienation and
isolation like you know what I mean I so
were you in a loop because of that yes
oh absolutely it was a complete Loop of
believing this getting into an argument
with somebody that reinforced the ideas
that I already had and at every fork in
the road that I had come to with that
that was a little hypocritical or maybe
there's something wrong there I didn't
seek out trying to find the cracks in
what I was believing I just sought
reinforcement so whenever I was in an
argument with somebody it wasn't really
about the Crux of what I was saying or
what I was advocating for it was always
they're a racist they're a misogynist so
anything that they say doesn't even
matter uh and I shouldn't even take into
account uh as far as questioning my own
self and having a healthy degree of
skepticism so I was in this constant
Loop of yes I believe this this is what
my identity is if somebody argues with
me it's because they're not on the same
page as me and they in fact hate
something about my identity and it just
looped back and forth three years
um
there's no better way to study scripture
and develop a dedicated prayer life than
with hallow hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S and the
number one Catholic app in the world
it's filled with studies meditations and
Reflections including the number one
Christian podcast the Bible in a year
download Hala today and try their Advent
prey 25 challenge a 25-day journey
through Bible stories from both the Old
and New Testament leading up to the
birth of Jesus these meditations are led
by cast members from the largest
Christian streaming Series in history
The Chosen Advent pray 25 will help grow
your understanding of mankind and
develop a disciplined prayer habit
during a season when our discipline is
put to the test
download Hollow for three months
completely free at hallow.com shorten
that's hallow.com Jordan give yourself
the gift of Peace calm and disciplined
this Christmas go to hallow.com Jordan
today
well people who are listening might be
asking well why should you subject your
own beliefs to criticism and like when I
wrote my first book
which is called maps of meaning I spend
a lot of time writing it but then I
spent a lot of time with hammer and
tongs trying to break every sentence so
I'd read a lot of nature by that point
and Nietzsche described himself as
someone who philosophized with a hammer
and so what he meant by that first of
all was that he was capable of
delivering devastating philosophical
blows which is certainly the case I
don't know if there's ever been a
philosopher who was more
explosive than Nietzsche in the
psychological and social sense but it
also meant that whenever he put forward
a proposition he would spend a
tremendous amount of time trying to
throw every possible argument he could
formulate at that proposition to see if
he could break it and then he'd only
keep the propositions he couldn't break
so I tried to do that with maps of
meaning I figure I rewrote every
sentence about 50 times trying to see is
there any way is there any argument I
can come up with that will get
underneath this proposition and make it
feel
weak and unsteady to me and I only kept
the now you might say well why bother
with all that why not just be
comfortable in your beliefs and the
answer is look there's going to come in
your time in your life for sure
might happen every day to some degree
where
what you believe and how you predicate
your actions is going to be subjected to
unbelievably severe stress and that
might be an argument you know or
especially if the argument gets
vicious and Intense or if it's a
long-term argument in the relationship
or it might be that you encounter
something tragic in your life
if your beliefs aren't stress tested
like in some serious manner then they're
going to fall apart just when you most
need them and then you're going to be in
serious trouble so finding yourself in
one of these Loops where you don't test
your beliefs and you just discount
everything that might be a challenge
because of the hypothetical you know
quasi-satanic nature of the person who's
questioning you means that you're
allowing yourself to live inside a house
of cards essentially and then as soon as
you are stressed in some real sense
you're going to just fall apart now you
said you were miserable and angry and so
was that most of the time
yeah it was it was most of the time and
that could have been due to to other
factors but I do think what I believed
was was really a part of that and the
the lack of true testing of what I
believed I think a lot of people
misconstrue a test with having a a cause
of stress and I think the more you test
your beliefs the more comfortable you
will be in them so now I'm way more
comfortable going into back and forth
with people and and debating whereas
before I wasn't and I think it's because
I was really insecure in what it was
that I believed but so confident in
espousing it and just so strong in in
being really forthright I was the person
who would wear those activist t-shirts
to school every day knowing that it was
going to rile people up and that it was
going to cause some sort of discussion
to happen uh so
what really had made me upset in the
life that I was leading was just waking
up every day looking at the world
through this lens of Injustice you know
every cross look was racist every off
comment was misogyny and when you view
the world that way and you're looking
for those things not just saying that
you believe that they are real but
looking for them everything you see is
going to be that thing so right you're
awesome evil place right well you also
put yourself in a position yeah that's
interesting too because you put yourself
in a position then when even when casual
interactions let's call them
microaggressions for lack of a better
word are and Casual misunderstandings
are instantly elevated in your
perception to the status of high moral
crimes so it isn't some it isn't just
that someone's annoyed at you or
someone's just having a bad day it's
that you're dealing with a racist or a
misogynist right which is a core
evaluation of their character
and I can give you an example of just
how bad it was because people will will
think about things and go well that
probably was a microaggression and it
probably was racism but I I was so
obsessed with it that as a kid I had
learned that if somebody wanted to touch
my hair which is very curly and very odd
for the place that I was living in
because I was surrounded by a lot of
white people with straight hair I was
told that if somebody asked to touch my
hair or somebody came and wanted to look
at my braids that was racism being
played out in real time and that they
were trying to express how different I
was and really belittle me so this would
happen all the time to me in school kids
would walk up and go oh I love your
curly hair can I touch your hair and
that was evil to me that was racism
shining right in my face so you can
imagine probably how bad that was for me
believing these things as a young a
young person
yeah yeah well that yeah that's def now
interesting that tone of voice that you
used there when you were talking about
those kids that would come up to you
when you mimic them the way you mimic
them was by by uh what would you call it
acting out the vocal intonations of a
curious kid not as someone who's being
mean and so what do you what do you now
think those kids were doing how do you
look at how and what do you think would
have been a better way for you to look
at that when you were a kid
oh the the best way I could have looked
at that as a child was oh my gosh
somebody is displaying interest in me
how how wonderful a thing that somebody
saw something that was different to what
they normally saw and and felt the need
to point that out and to ask me about it
they were genuinely curious about how my
hair came to be this way and if I had
viewed the world in that light um I
would have been such a such a happy
little child and unfortunately I had the
exact opposite experience
yeah you know I read a great book a long
while back called bullying what we know
and what we can do about it and you know
we have this idea that bullies find kids
who have something abnormal about them
and then Target them because of that
abnormality but this gentleman
um Dan always great psychologist
pointed out that at least 75 percent of
kids have some obvious
um let's call it
um deviation from the norm that could be
picked out by a bully you know it could
be something as simple as wearing
glasses or having red hair or being a
little short or being a little taller
being a little thin or being a little
fat you know you can just multiply the
the peculiarities endlessly and that
that in and of itself isn't enough to
generate bullying the bullies tend to
focus on an identifiable
anomaly but then they
they're looking for kids who overreact
when they're teased a little bit and
then it's that combination of
sensitivity hypersensitivity to
provocation plus perhaps an anomaly that
makes someone into a bully victim and so
well you can you can kind of see there
you have this situation where there was
something about you about your hair that
made you identifiably different but the
kids could have been both testing you
and checking you out in a curious way
and then whether that would spiral into
something that would be true bullying
and intimidation would be dependent in
large degree to a large degree on your
own reaction
right yeah and I I've I've struggled
with a long time for a long time of just
going back and taking accountability for
for my part in things and when I went
through this journey of realizing oh
maybe I don't believe in this leftist
sort of woke Dogma a lot of that time I
spent blaming other people why were
people teaching me these things what
institutions were at play when it came
to me getting this information and I
took no accountability for my part in
being susceptible to the information and
what made me want to believe these
things why was I ripe for the picking as
far as a person who was willing to fall
for some of the stuff that I was hearing
and that's still something that I'm I'm
thinking through to this day well you
did say something interesting and this
is probably worth diving into too you
said that
despite the fact that your knowledge was
shallow well you're not very old and you
weren't you know 10 years ago
particularly you weren't very old
despite your knowledge being shallow and
despite it not being your knowledge you
were very confident about displaying it
and displaying it in some sense proudly
and you know pride is always being
regarded as one of the cardinal sins and
so it seems to me that part of what
set you up for this apart from the
the characteristics of your particular
background was also that it there was
something in it that was an appeal to
like a prideful narcissism right and I'm
not diagnosing you as a narcissist right
don't get don't get that don't get that
wrong I'm really not I'm I'm trying to
understand why well as you said Carl
Jung said you know that
every projection needed a hook and so
so you always have to ask yourself even
if you were enticed down the garden
pathway by woke Educators and by your
own mother to some degree what was it in
you that
helped you respond in a way that made
you even more vulnerable to that kind of
propagandization than you might have
otherwise been and you said you wore
these shirts proudly you were looking
for a fight in some sense so what what
do you think was at the bottom of that
Pride what were you taking pride in was
it you standing up for the underdog like
what is it that that
wearing those shirts was doing for you
do you think yeah I think I felt really
different as a child growing up in the
environment that I grew up in and I
always felt like I I had sticked out
regardless of what I did so I I think I
just leaned into that a little bit more
and thought okay well if I'm going to
stick out for these things that I can't
control I'm going to take control of
something and I'm gonna stand out even
more and couple that with feeling very
virtuous for for doing it uh I think it
was just a recipe for for disaster
because it made me feel like I'm a good
person doing a good thing plus I'm
standing out plus all these other people
aren't willing to do this good thing
that I'm doing and I get to tell them
about it in any given moment and it was
just a mixture of feeling really
insecure and yeah yeah well so that's an
interesting thing eh because
we all do believe I think in some real
sense that
a good person should do good things and
some of that would be a certain amount
of self-sacrifice for the benefit of
others you know and if you're sensible
about that you you'd say well you
shouldn't sacrifice yourself to the
point of being a martyr because that
becomes counterproductive but the
problem with that goodness I guess this
is why there's an injunction in the
gospels against praying in public the
problem with that virtue or that
goodness is that you can start to
trumpet it as a differentiating moral
virtue right and so you can start to use
your hypothetical care for the poor and
oppressed as a marker for your
Superior social status and the
inviolability of your beliefs and so
then it starts to move you can see that
there's a slippery slope there from
compassionate virtue to overweening
Pride and you said in your case it was
also exaggerated by the fact that well
man if you were going to be different
you know if you were fated to be
different in some ways than by God you
were gonna play that hand to its fullest
and that's also an attraction you know
and an adaptation
sure yeah and that that's exactly what
happened it was just me me playing into
something but also being reinforced that
it was right all the time I was super
involved in the activism that I was
doing so when I wasn't at school I go to
work with my mom and and volunteer there
and I ended up graduating high school
and I was so involved that I got a job
at her organization so when we go back
to that Loop it was just my own
negativity and insecurity my own
willingness to want to be different for
for the sake of just being different
making myself feel virtuous and doing so
and then being reinforced by the adult
structures that were around me for being
a young person willing to do the work
which is really so often what we see
with the David hogs out of marsh for our
lives and the Greta thunbergs it was
just older people saying this is so
great that you're doing it and you're
just like Obama oh yeah a lot of people
told me at the time oh my God oh my God
yeah well you know I was thinking about
Greta last night so it might be worth
just talking about her a little bit so
I was trying to put myself in her shoes
so imagine first of all that you're 13.
and then imagine that you're a little on
the autistic side
and then imagine that you have a very
domineering mother who's perfectly
willing to use you for her political
purposes and then so now she's instilled
this Terror into you that the world is
coming to an apocalyptic end and you're
and that that there are evil and
malevolent forces conspiring to make
that happen and that basically
constitutes the entire patriarchal
structure of Western civilization and
all of its industry and all of that so
that's the background you come out of
and now you're 13 and you start to
Parrot some of your mother's ideas of
course they're not really her ideas but
their ideas that have possessed her to
you start to Parrot them okay and then
what happens you're 13. well what
happens is
like 50 year old adult male leaders all
over the world fall at your feet and
treat you like you're the Oracle of
Delphi and so then what the hell do you
think if you're 13 and confused and a
bit autistic and your mother's a bit
domineering you think
oh my God all these things she's telling
me that are so terrifying must be true
because all these
well-positioned men who run the world
are treating the revelations of my
childhood fear as if they're so
important that they should be broadcast
on every news station and should start
to become fundamental government policy
and so like how the hell how the hell
would you possibly respond if you were
13 except with a massive magnification
of your Terrors like oh the world's in
such bad shape that I the 13 year old
autistic child from Scandinavia now
seemed to be the leading Oracle in the
world on the environmental economic
front
it's so it's so sad for her like I can't
imagine how someone in that situation
couldn't be
on the edge of existential Terror
constantly
yeah I've relate to her a lot and you
know I feel a lot of compassion and
sympathy for her mother as well because
from my perspective with my mom having
gone through this really twisted journey
of having to come to her and say you
know what that stuff that I learned when
I was younger really did have a negative
effect and here's how and her just being
shocked and that oh I'm so you know I
thought I was doing the right thing I
thought I was doing the compassionate
thing and I thought I was alerting you
to the snake that's sitting out in the
front yard and that's my responsibility
as a mother to do that so I feel for
Greta's mother I feel for her and
I I also feel for the people who look at
a young person and say look at this
young person leading the way and using
the power of a 13 year old which is just
really very much misplaced to to push
forward a movement but it is just a
Twisted Twisted cycle
yeah well I mean she's in an impossible
situation because I don't see how she
could possibly question herself or her
doubts given the unbelievably
overwhelming response to her Revelations
so she yeah she's in an awful situation
okay so we talked a little bit about the
role that your own Temptations played in
setting you up for this propaganda
although you were pretty much surrounded
by it too which is you know that makes
it also very difficult to let's say
escape from so how old were you when you
started working after schools at your
mom's organization and then how old were
you when you started working for her
full-time
I was 15 when I had started volunteering
and 17 when I started working full-time
okay and you did that after you
graduated from high school
yes as soon as I graduated from high
school I thought no college for me let's
let's make myself a full-time activist
and and that's what I did yeah right
well okay that's okay a couple of things
there so another thing that really used
to bother me at the universities and I
started to discuss this with some of my
professional peers
just before it became impossible for me
to continue working at the University
we have this idea that we tell young
people all the time and I really do
think this is an Insidious invitation to
their prideful narcissism that the way
first of all that they should be
changing the world you know which is a
lot to change for people who haven't
even been able to live independently yet
and also that if you do want to change
the world which is what you should do
and what you could do the way you do
that is by being an activist and
activist has become professionalized
since the mid 60s and so an activist
seems to me to be someone who
hypothetically advocates for the
oppressed which is already a moral
danger it's because like what the hell
made you advocate for the oppressed did
they elect you as why are you the
spokesman and what gives you that moral
virtue so you know those are major
questions but also it it comes with it
this temptation because if you're an
activist you're almost always against
something right you're against industry
you're against fossil fuels you're
against the patriarchy you're against
the racists like you're always
identifying the problem with the world
uh as being something that some other
person who isn't good like you is doing
and then what we do is we present young
people in high school and in University
with the notion that well there's if you
really care about the world there's
nothing more honorable than you could do
that you could possibly do than to
become an activist and I really kind of
think that in some sense there are
almost no lower calling than activist
yes I would agree with you and I I think
it's within our nature especially as
young people to get obsessed with this
idea of radical transformation and this
lure of of transformation and uh it
wasn't until I met Dave Rubin who I'm
sure you're familiar with and he he put
out this quote of you know when I was on
this side of things I was trying to
control the world now that I'm out of it
I'm trying to understand the world and
that's something that a lot of young
people are not obsessed with they don't
want to understand the world and their
place with it within it they feel a
sense of discomfort and they want to
attribute that sense of discomfort to
something else and find what is a common
enemy and it's really easy to find a
common enemy if you listen to anybody
who is obsessed with this with this woke
ideology
Shopify is the all-in-one Commerce
platform trusted by millions of
entrepreneurs to create their online
store and so much more Shopify makes it
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
whether you're selling succulents or
stilettos start selling with Shopify and
join the platform simplifying Commerce
for millions of businesses worldwide
with Shopify you'll customize your
online store to your brand discover new
customers and build the relationships
that will keep them coming back Shopify
covers all the sales channels to
successfully grow your business from an
in-person POS system to an all-in-one
e-commerce platform even across social
media platforms like Tick Tock Facebook
and Instagram thanks to 24 7 support and
free on-demand business courses Shopify
is here to help you succeed every step
of the way it's how every minute new
sellers around the world make their
first sale with Shopify and you can too
sign up for a free trial at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp to start
selling online today that shop fi.com
slash jbp
okay so so maybe someone might level a
criticism at you and say okay look you
know for a long time you were left-wing
activist but now you're just a
right-wing activist and so what how
would you defend yourself how do you
defend yourself because I'm sure that
ideas occurred to you how do you
investigate that charge and what do you
think is different about you working for
Prager you know which is a well-known
hypothetically right-wing you know
conspiratorial organization which seems
in some sense activist on its surface
how do you distinguish between what
you're doing now and what you were doing
before and how do you know that you're
not equally deluded but on other on the
other side of the of the political
Spectrum
yeah sure the way that I know I'm I'm
not as deluded as I was before is that I
did go through a period of delusion when
I recognized that I was not a leftist I
immediately went oh well I must be on
the right then and I self subscribe
myself to the right wing talking points
for for quite some time and then I don't
know what happened but a moment came to
me where I went wait a second I must
have this propensity to just latch
myselves onto things because I've just
done the same thing on the other side
and I really had to look Within Myself
and find where where do I truly disagree
uh with my my previous self and where do
I agree with my previous self and there
are plenty of back and forth that we'll
get into with the with the employees
here at pragery where we disagree on on
many things and that was certainly not
an experience that I had when I was
working for that left leading
organization now that could be that
organization on its own uh
wrote an article this week talking about
how leftist organizations all across the
United States are collapsing in enough
in in into themselves because they can't
handle any internal dissent so I think
that okay so one of the things you said
about Prager was that you get to say
what you want and that you can disagree
and so and you also implied that imagine
that you're trying to make your way and
so first of all you're on the left you
have an oversimplified world view and
then you find out some errors and then
bang you vacillate over to the right and
an oversimplified View and you find some
errors like what you're doing is you're
trying to develop a much more
differentiated and detail-oriented
political philosophy right because
that's part of being matured wise and so
you're going to oscillate back and forth
like that now you said
you don't think you're merely being an
activist now because you're working for
an organization where where disagreement
is actually is it tolerated or
encouraged and do the Prager people
actually
do they let you say what you need to say
do they encourage you to do that and how
do you know that you're not just pulling
yourself into alignment with their views
for instrumental reasons I mean people
have asked me the same questions about
my work with the daily wire let's say
sure I yeah I'd say it's both tolerated
and encouraged and and we can be both at
the same time and and when I come and do
my show I I know that my show is my
words and I know that it's my thoughts
and I I feel comfortable now whereas I
didn't before saying you know what I I
don't agree with maybe that five minute
video that we put out this week or I
don't want to have a certain guest on on
the show to discuss uh this sort of view
of things and that is always encouraged
and taken to heart and they go okay
great we don't ever want you to put your
name on something that is not your
thinking or or your belief so I have
much more freedom today than I had
before when I was working for that
left-leaning organization and I was
having these thoughts that were
dissidents to the subscribed narrative I
didn't feel comfortable even saying that
or even coming to a point of
confrontation with anybody because I
knew that my job was contingent upon me
believing the the list of things that I
was meant to believe and now I get to
come and say ah I don't think I agree
with you on that and it's actually taken
in stride and people want to talk about
it
okay okay so one of the ways you know
that you're not merely Towing the party
line now is that you have a wider range
of play available to you without getting
in getting into trouble okay so how else
do you
steer is a good question how have you
learned to distinguish
between those words that are yours and
those words that merely make you a
mouthpiece of an ideology
yeah I mean I guess I I'm not afraid to
to disagree I think if I was your
typical right-leaning conservative
person I would be talking about I don't
know Christianity I don't happen to be a
religious person I'm I'm agnostic
atheist I guess is what you you would
say and I always just try to take in
information and really deduce down
where people are right where people are
wrong on both sides of things like I'll
take in both both narratives both the
left and the right and and see okay
where are they right on this and where
are they wrong and why is that the case
and on the right where are they right on
this and where are they wrong and that's
the case and I take it upon myself to
hopefully be even-handed in criticism of
both sides so there will be episodes
that conservatives watch my show and
they go I absolutely do not agree with
anything you said and here's why and
there's episodes that I put out where
where leftists disagree with what I have
to say so I don't know that I have a
particular process for Discerning
whether or not I'm truly using the words
that come from my own mind but I I can
certainly tell that with reaction to the
content that I'm saying that well I must
be I must be saying what's true to
myself because I'm pissing off two
groups of people equally okay well that
well that seems to be a reasonable
marker I mean you said
you also implied something as we talked
you said that when you were a mouthpiece
for the party line as a young person
a lot of the time you were miserable and
angry and you had a chip on your
shoulder and you saw a lot of hostility
in the world and so and there isn't any
evidence of that in the way that you
conduct yourself certainly not in this
discussion and not when I saw you on
stage like you don't seem to be carrying
along around a lot of bitterness and
resentment and so you know I have this
byline on my on my email response truth
is the antidote to suffering
and you know one of the things that I
think is reasonable is is to note that
if you are using your own words that
gives you a sense of solidity internal
solidity and confidence in what you're
saying like there's a there's an element
that's foundational there it doesn't
have that sense of falseness and
narcissistic Pride that goes along with
claiming false moral virtue for merely
mouthing the dictates of a given
ideology
sure you know what that's a very great
point and that's something that hadn't
come to mind yeah I would say I am far
more sound in myself and far more
comfortable I think with admitting that
I was wrong or saying I don't know when
it comes to right right whereas before I
would you would never hear me say I
don't know which is really scary to
think about in retrospect and now I'm so
comfortable looking at an issue and
going you know what I don't no I don't
know
yeah well there's two Terrors there
right that there is a terror in not
knowing because it means you have to
face your ignorance and there's no
shortage of that but there's also that
totalitarian Terror which is the
opposite to that which is well if I had
my eye together I would have an answer
for everything and that's a hell of a
burden especially when you're 15 because
or 16 it's like well what the hell do
you know
and and it's hard to understand that
there's actually a relief in being able
to throw up your hands and say well I
don't know what the answer to that is
and I could go investigate and but it
that it's also okay that I don't know
and then that opens up doors of
exploration for me but you know this
this uh this is something I learned when
I was probably about your age you know
and maybe you'd find it useful I
understood
it was in 1985 to 83 something like that
so I was about 21 yeah I just bought
exactly your age
um I like to win arguments you know and
I had got a lot of positive attention
for being smart and being verbal when I
was a kid and so I had a fair bit of
let's say intellectual Pride which I
doubt I've shaken completely and uh
I like to be able to win arguments and I
could usually win an argument if I set
out to do so and so I thought that if
you won an argument you were right and
certainly being married has disabused me
of that notion by the way and uh and and
then I realized that I was often saying
things just so that I would win
arguments and be right
and then I also noticed that when I was
doing that I had a deep sense of
falsehood and disquiet right and I felt
that when I was really paying attention
I could see that doing that made me weak
it made me weak and defensive and
prideful and narcissistic all of those
things and then insistent that I was
right and kind of totalitarian and so
then I started to listen to what I was
saying and to feel it out and I was
reading Carl Rogers at the same time
because I was starting to get interested
in the clinical world and he talked
about the necessity of authenticity and
he believed that your actions and your
words should be in alignment but not
only that that your physiological being
and your word should be in alignment he
said if you paid enough attention you
could tell when you were let's say not
being true to your core self something
like that and for me that manifested
itself as a sense of weakness and so I
kind of learned to feel my way along I
always think about it as
sort of trying to find imagine you're
walking across a giant swamp and there
are Stones Under the surface but you
can't see them in the murky water but
you can feel them out so you can feel
where you could step you could take the
next step and find Solid Ground
and you can do that with your words
you know you can feel
and I think that's a
a test for the the authenticity and uh
and and the truth of the words is that
they're not prideful they're not
designed to win they're designed to
provide you with a firm foundation under
your feet and I think to some degree
well I'm wondering I suppose to some
degree if that's how you know
to what degree that's how you know for
example at prageru when you should hold
your ground and and say what you need to
say
certainly I and it's interesting because
I've I think I've managed to learn that
at least in the political sense when it
comes to the job that I do but in a
personal sense I still struggle with
exactly what you were talking about sort
of feeling the stones and and
recognizing things in yourself before
the words come out of your mouth so now
politically because I've gone through
all of this back and forth and really
having to contend with myself and with
other people now I'm I'm fine and I'm
calm and I'll listen to a story and I'll
have this idea of well let's wait let's
wait to find more information even
though something immediately wants to
attack somebody else let's wait and hear
more whereas sometimes in my personal
life my my turnaround on recognizing my
defensiveness is about a 24-hour period
which my boyfriend is struggling with
right now right right well well that's
interesting you know like that's played
itself out in our marriage and I would
say
um I'll talk about my wife momentarily I
would say that when we first got married
the turnaround for her was about 24
hours years and she's got that down to
about 30 seconds now
yeah and that's yeah so I hope to be
just like her well you know well if you
practice that you know and and if you
practice and it is that kind of that's
humility by the way really it's like
if you listen with humility
you're always listening with the idea
that
you're probably still pretty stupid and
maybe this person will say something
that will make you slightly less stupid
if you listen hard enough
right and that's such a gift right
because if you're stupid
you're going to run into a wall because
of it at some point and so if someone
who's talking to you
can tell you where you're stupid well
what a deal for you and the thing that's
so interesting about that too is that
you're way more likely to be told where
you're stupid by someone who doesn't
agree with you
yes a hundred percent and it's
interesting that when I I meet people
like protesters who have this very
shallow depiction of myself and are
telling me that I'm stupid or racist or
all these things for some reason I treat
this person who is so far removed from
my life with far more compassion than if
somebody who I care about is coming
forward and saying hey you did this this
stupid thing and I don't know if it's
because the relationship that I have
with the person that is that is deep and
and caring has a little bit more sting
when criticism is given and and that's
why I immediately jumped to defense
whereas with this person you know it
doesn't truly matter all that much what
somebody on a college campus thinks uh
so it's something that I continue to
struggle with but I've I've turned a
two-week period of turn around into a
24-hour one so okay well that's that's
pretty good well no that's no it should
like if you practice that diligently you
can get to turn around really quick you
know and that's really we were talking
about the religious front you know
that's really a confession and
repentance by the way
that's a compressed well because the
confession is
so first of all you can think about it
as recognition of sin okay so what does
sin mean technically it means to to miss
the mark there's two derivations there's
hamartia from the Greek
which was an archery term so to sin
means to miss the mark and there's one
from the Hebrew which was Chet if I
remember correctly and it also meant to
miss the target so imagine that the
religious transformation in its
microstructure is something like
admission of sin which is well I missed
the Target and and then there's a
confessional element to it which is well
here's how I missed the target you know
I wasn't aiming at the right target I
wasn't careful enough
Etc and then there's the repentance
which is well I'd rather not do that
again and then the religious Vision at
least on the Christian side and it's not
unique to Christianity is that if you go
through that process of of recognition
of sin and confession and repentance
then there's Redemption
and that is I really think that's the
cycle of growth right I don't think you
ever learn anything important without
going through those four things that's
sort of been routinized in the in the in
the re and and made mythological in the
in the religious context but it's a
useful thing to know because that's a
place where the learning that you're
undertaking and your explicit
description of the learning and that
religious system of ideation that's a
place where they dovetail
yeah and I can imagine pride is the one
thing that is standing as a barrier to a
force of those steps yeah yeah well good
well that's a very astute observation
because the precondition for that cycle
of transformation is humility
and you know there's there's my my wife
prays this Jesus prayer and I'm going to
mangle it because I don't know it that
well but it's something like Jesus
Christ have mercy on my soul uh a sinner
and and the Orthodox Christians some of
them pray that continually and you might
say well what exactly are they doing and
the answer is well they're trying to
remind themselves that they're stupid
and fallible and you might say well that
sucks because who wants to be reminded
constantly that they're stupid
infallible but if that makes you more
attentive
and more able to go through this cycle
of transformation because now you're
attending to the places where you might
be an error then it's a facilitator of
growth and it is a facilitator of growth
to understand that
there's a lot more possibility in what
you don't know than there than there is
power in what you do know
yeah did I'm curious did you ever
struggle with with pride getting in the
way by by virtue of having the job that
you have because so many people are
looking to you and taking in your words
as is very much right uh in In This Very
dedicated fashion does that that ever
come as a barrier in your personal life
with your own argument well I I think I
think that I sort I was fortunate you
know in some sense because I didn't
become well known till I was pretty old
like I was in my mid-50s you know and
I'd been a professor at Harvard and at
the University of Toronto for 20 years
and so I had a pretty good reputation
among my students and I had some
practice at what that was like and then
I developed a bit of a media following
in Ontario and I got a bit of experience
on the broader social landscape before
things burst you know things burst
forward around me now so I I was older
when this all happened and that was
helpful but I also as I indicated in our
conversation I started to sort a lot of
this out when I was about your age and I
realized that I had a lot of
intellectual Pride you know and that's
the problem with being smart
is that when you're smart
because you get a lot of positive
attention for it it's really easy to
overvalue it to confuse intelligence
with virtue
and to confuse the fact that you're
intelligent let's say with the idea that
you're valuable and good and that's
dangerous because it means that people
who aren't as intelligent aren't as
valuable and good and that's not a very
good conclusion to draw but it also
draws you in in a prideful way and like
I said I like to win arguments and I
always thought well if I won the
argument I was smarter and better and I
realized around your age that Not only
was that not true like seriously not
true because just because someone can't
formulate an argument doesn't mean they
don't have a point this is something you
definitely learn when you're married
you know because your partner might be
upset with you and unable to aren't
articulate it and you might be able to
mount a pretty damn good defense but
they still might be right and you should
listen
so because maybe they'll stop you from
falling into a pit but I also started to
understand too that in that intellectual
Pride well the the figure of Lucifer and
Satan Lucifer in particular so he's a
variant of the idea of what satanic and
evil Lucifer is the morning star in the
spirit of Enlightenment and Milton
characterized Lucifer as God's highest
Angel gone most spectacularly wrong and
Lucifer is like Scar in The Lion King
you know scars smarter than Mustafa and
but he's alienated and isolated and
bitter and part of that's intellectual
Pride a huge part of it and there's
there's a tremendous intellectual pride
in the totalitarian impulse and so I
started to understand that to the degree
that I was characterized by
intellectually by intellectual pride and
capitalizing on you know a talent that
was given to me in some sense by god
let's say you know by the Transcendent
because I'm not responsible for my own
intelligence whatever it might be right
that's just who I am I didn't do that
it's just it's I have no more to do with
that in some sense than how tall I am
it's just how it is and to and then I
started to understand that being
prideful in that manner
was participating in the same process
that led to totalitarian atrocity and
then that just scared the hell out of me
I hope
you know I hope it scared me better well
I hope while you do hope well you know
my house for years was covered with
Soviet paintings
these realist paintings and a lot of
them featured Lenin and uh Marx and
uh Trotsky a lot of the real
intellectual acolytes of the communist
movement and they were huge paintings
some of them were nine by twelve and
literally my house was covered with them
and you know much to the Chagrin of my
wife to some degree although she uh
played along but part of that was
to remember
you know to remember how attractive
these totalizing ideologies can be how
much of a Temptation they are to Pride
especially allied with something like
compassion and how unbelievably brutal
and terrible that is and so I I try to
have that in the back of my mind all the
time I want to step forward carefully I
don't want to
fall prey to that intellectual or moral
pride and like I said I'm old enough so
I think I can handle it and then I would
also say you know I have a lot of people
around me who
keep me in check
I have good friends many of whom have
been have had incredibly successful
careers extremely intelligent people and
capable and blunt and if I deviate some
of them on the left and some of them on
the right and if I deviate they phone me
and say you know I don't think you
handle that very well you should get
your act together and then we fight
about it I did a video with Greg hurwitz
and Jonathan pagio about my the tweets
that got me banned you know where we
tried to delve into
the utility and morality of my behavior
Twitter makes you impulsive and you know
I can be impulsive on Twitter and so and
I I made some nasty comments on Twitter
and
I spent a lot of time talking to my
friends and my family about
you know was that straight and right or
was it prideful and impulsive and
well so I have lots of people around me
who help and then I'm also I'm hoping
I'm terrified enough of where
intellectual Pride goes to
you know to keep my ego in check
sure and there's there's also this
element of being a person who thinks
you're always trying to do the right
thing and trying to do the right thing
is different from doing the right thing
and I've I've learned that very recently
and as far as having people having
people who keep you in check it's been
it's been majorly important for me as
well I mean I've been with a man for a
year who now whenever I do something
that is wrong or could even be
misconstrued is wrong he goes hey you
know I saw that you did this thing and
having so much of your life being filmed
which I'm sure you're accustomed to it's
a really it's really something that you
have to keep in mind because one 30
second moment you've had which would
normally be seen by nobody can be seen
by millions and you will be held to that
belief or that statement for the rest of
your life whether or not that's a
rightful thing to do or not uh with with
the cancel culture that we're dealing
with right now so to have somebody there
to say you could have said it this way
or I know what you meant to say but
here's how it could have been done
better is just such an important thing
to have for everybody
yeah yeah well you know there's
advantages to that I mean I've
been required let's say to temper my
public Behavior
more in a more civilized manner since
I've been in the situation that you
described which is so there's two
elements to that first of all if I'm
ever rude to anyone who knows me who
knows of me
first of all they will never forget that
for the rest of their life and they will
tell everyone they know
and you don't need that to happen very
many times before your reputation
deservedly takes a major hit so I do my
best to be hyper alert when I'm in
public in places that I might be
irritated normally like airports and so
forth because I really don't like
airports and uh not that anybody
particularly does but it is it is kind
of useful to be called to be on your
best behavior all the time like that but
it is definitely useful to have someone
around who is watching you and helping
you you know modify your behavior so
that you aren't being impulsive and and
prideful any more than is absolutely
necessary yeah you're going to be in a
rough situation eh because you're really
young and you do have to
assuming that your career trajectory
stays upward which seems you know
reasonably probable bar in catastrophe
you're really going to have to watch
yourself constantly and so that could be
good but it's not nothing to have to do
that
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
yeah I think the moments where I'll find
the most pressure in it is probably when
we're doing live shows because you never
know what's going to come out of your
mouth for the most part when you're live
and I I have been known to be a very
fast-paced person and that is helpful
and hurtful in so many ways but as far
as meeting people you spoke to something
interesting there are times where you
meet people in your most uncomfortable
moments in life and I there have been
moments where I you know I've been at
the hospital seeing a loved one and
someone walks in and wants to say hi or
a nurse or something like that and it's
just so interesting to have to take that
in and go well this is a moment and you
have to make this moment for this person
despite what's what's going on in your
personal life and there's something so
powerful about having to do that as a
person not to you know step out of the
the realm of humility but it's very
meditative to take on an uncomfortable
moment and make it comfortable for for
somebody else it's very powerful
powerful thing to be able to do and a
skill that I hopefully have learned yeah
right well you know what would be a good
skill for everyone to learn you know
because the yes the the idea there is
something like
you are required to be good regardless
of whatever tragedy happens to be
unfolding in your life at the moment and
I think that's right I mean you know
part of the reason that people are
inclined not to be good so they become
resentful and bitter is because terrible
things have happened to them and that's
genuinely the case now you know you can
blow out of proportion something and
find a reason for resentment but lots of
times people have been really hurt and
you might say well don't I have a reason
to be resentful and bitter and the
answer is bloody well right you have a
reason to be resentful and bitter and it
might be a good reason but but two
things first of all
that doesn't mean that you get to stop
trying to be good
and second it also doesn't mean that
everybody's had a rough time is now no
longer good now
you know in my life I've met lots of
people because I was a clinician and a
professor and well and now you know I
met literally hundreds of thousands of
people but
I learned
at least 25 years ago that
it's often the best people who've been
through the worst things now if you go
through something terrible it can really
embitter you and and take you out and
make you malevolent and you have your
reasons but I've met people who had
lives so brutal that they're almost
Beyond imagining who were so deep and
good that it was literally a miracle to
meet them and I met a lot of people like
that I had people in my clinical
practice who were just Jesus I had this
one woman she would she didn't have
anything going for her like her family
was utterly insane her mother was a
delusional alcoholic schizophrenic whose
boyfriend was paranoid and used to
torture her to death about being
possessed literally possessed she was
very intellectually impaired uh she was
overweight she was unattractive she
dressed like a straight person she just
Jesus she had a rough life man in every
way she'd been in a mental hospital
inpatient Ward for like years and she
came to me
hypothetically because she was afraid of
other people she used to kind of walk up
to people like this you know she was so
shy she couldn't even look at people and
it turned out that the real reason she
came this outpatient clinic that I was
working out at a place called the
Douglas hospital she'd been in an
inpatient Ward
and man the people in those inpatient
Wards they were so devastated they'd
been there for like 30 years these were
people who hadn't been let back on the
streets during de-institutionalization
and so it was like Dante's Inferno
walking through those rewards man and uh
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest had
nothing on that place I tell you and she
had been in that Ward and she had a dog
that she took care of and she had this
idea that she could take her dog out for
a walk and then maybe she could take
some of those inpatients out for a walk
and that's why she'd come to see me so
you had this woman whose life was
Jesus man she was
she was facing an impenetrable wall
everywhere she looked and yet her
attitude was you know I've met some
people who had it worse than me and
maybe there's something I could do to
help it was stunning
and so those type of people that you
meet are so powerful
yeah well you know you're the fact that
you're suffering doesn't justify your
immorality
and that's yeah you're you're called
upon to act nobly regardless of your
catastrophe and not only is that a good
thing to learn better for the world yeah
it's going to be better for the world
around you and it's going to be better
for you I I mean I don't know that this
has been studied or anything but feeling
hatred and being super reactive or
sensitive to things that have gone wrong
in your life I truly believe eats away
at your your body and mind as a person
and all the people that I've met who
have been the most powerful in my life
have had some of the worst things happen
to them and they approach people with a
smile and they are calm and they are
collected in in some of the worst
moments you could possibly imagine and
to be able to master that as a person I
think is probably one of the most
powerful Journeys that I'll go on or
anybody will go on in their life well it
has been studied I would say to some
degree you know it depends on how you it
depends on how broadly in some sense
it depends on how far you can see the
research extending so here's an example
um there is a a trait neuroticism which
is sensitivity to negative emotion
and that's anxiety and pain let's say
and people differ in their sensitivity
to those at Baseline
one of the things that makes people more
neurotic so experience negative emotion
is self-consciousness
and so really what that means is
literally what it means is the more you
think about yourself the more miserable
you are
and so that's worth knowing so if you're
always wondering how the world's
treating you and if you're a victim and
if you're always concerned about your
emotional state you will be miserable
because those concerns are the same
thing as being miserable
and so there's that bit of research that
bears on this issue but it's it's also
the case that we know that if you take a
a stance in life that's predicated on
the idea that what you're doing is
voluntarily confronting a challenge
then that's completely different
psychophysiologically neurologically
pharmacologically that's completely
different from having a stress thrust
upon you so if you're an active
Contender you're actually a different
psychophysiological organism than you
are if you're a passive recipient even
if it's the same level of challenge
you know that'd be the difference stress
and challenge that's clearly documented
all the way to the cellular level
okay so sitting sitting in the ice bath
willingly is better than having ice
water thrown at your face well in in
fact they're not only different they're
opposites so and the ice bath ideas and
interesting one I mean Wim Hoff who's
the world's Master at ice baths I mean
he's been plunging himself into cold
water for decades and he is so resistant
to cold and so in control of his
autonomic nervous system that it's kind
of miracle and so you know we actually
don't know the limit here like so here
I'll tell you something on the religious
front that's worth thinking about too in
relationship to this
um
discussion
you know there's an idea that's deep in
Western culture in so far as Western
culture is Christian is that the uh
that the world is founded on a sacrifice
right and that's that's what the
crucifix represents and European towns
were built around a church and the
church was built around an altar and the
altar was built around the idea of
sacrifice so the sacrifice the proper
sacrifice is at the center of the
community that's what that idea means
now you might ask well what's the proper
sacrifice and the answer is something
like the voluntary willingness to bury
your cross
and then you might say well what is your
cross and the answer to that is well
that's the catastrophe of your life
right that's the fact you'll be betrayed
the fact that you're going to die the
fact that you're going to be in pain the
fact that your loved ones will see you
suffer the fact that the mob will come
after you the fact that criminals might
be preferred to you
Etc it's all the potential catastrophes
of your life and then the sacrifice is
the idea that you you have to
you have to let your what would you say
you have to let your narrow ego go
enough so that you pick all that up
voluntarily all of that and then that
transforms it and I think I think that's
literally true I think that's what all
this that's what all the psychological
evidence points to is that if you adopt
uh stance of voluntary challenge even in
relationship to tragedy and malevolence
that that's the pathway to Transcendence
like truly yeah it's interesting it's
interesting that you say that because my
mother she she struggles with borderline
personality disorder and in a lot of the
therapy that she's underwent they talk
about this deep attachment to traumatic
events and not only the traumatic events
of your own life but of other people's
lives and her attachment to that is
often from the perspective of being
somebody outside of the traumatic event
and bearing no responsibility or
accountability now whether that's the
illness to blame or or your own personal
uh ability to contend with yourself it
truly does change your entire outlook on
life and it can be a very powerful thing
to take accountability for actions that
maybe had nothing to do with you well
okay so I got a I've got a practical
example of that that might be helpful
with your relationship so and and maybe
not but maybe it'll be helpful to
someone so now and then when my wife get
into an intractable battle
you know we'll both have that proclivity
to want to be right so you want to be
right because you don't want your
beliefs to fall apart and you want to be
right because then you don't have to go
through the inconvenience of having to
change so you have your reasons for
wanting to be right the problem with
that is you might not be right and plus
you have to live with this other person
and so you better sort out your
differences I don't think that's
compromised by the way I think that's
joint Union in a higher Vision but one
of the things we learned to do if we
could pull ourselves away from the fight
you know because you think things like
well you know some of the time I'm wrong
but this time she's definitely in the
wrong and I'm going to make that point
she feels the same way and so you know
then we
you know come to loggerheads we learn to
leave each other and go into our
separate rooms and then to meditate for
some period of time and here's the
meditation it's like okay
we're having this stupid argument
definitely my wife is wrong this time
for sure but there's some possibility
that I've done something stupid
sometime in the recent past or maybe
even in the distant past that made this
argument somewhat more likely you know
somewhat even though she's mostly wrong
and so what's so interesting about that
is if you sit and you ask yourself that
it's like what what did I do imperfectly
to increase the probability of this
event you will absolutely get an answer
you'll get some little fantasy some
memory some thought about something you
did and then if you go tell the person
that
then it takes all that Pride out of it
so she'll say you know what she did
wrong and I'll say what I did wrong and
then then we're both confronting the
situation like stupid people who have
something to learn instead of like
intellectually prideful people who are
definitely right and then we can well so
far inevitably inevitably we've been
able to construct a joint Vision out of
the argument you know that's better than
either of our a priori positions and
that that's that's also a Hallmark of a
healthy relationship it's not like you
meet in the middle or that you
compromise it's that you bring the
conflict together
its thesis antithesis synthesis
essentially you bring the conflict
together and you bring your two
viewpoints together and you meld a third
Viewpoint that's better than either of
the viewpoints you brought to bear on
the problem
and you can generally do that and being
having that humility that enables you to
examine what stupid thing you did to
muck up the relationship that's
you can you can meditate on that pretty
much forever right what stupid thing did
you do to muck things up that's that's
an inexhaustible Trevor Treasure Trove
of wisdom that is right and one of the
worst and most uncomfortable things that
we'll have to go through in our life too
since yet another challenge to to face
in full force uh in something yeah well
admittedly say I struggle with well you
know here here's something I learned as
a therapist this is also useful to know
um
it's not surprising that people shy away
from conflict especially if they're
agreeable and somewhat neurotic because
you don't want to have conflict with
someone if you're agreeable
and if your higher neuroticism it makes
you pretty upset
so you have your reasons not to want to
have the discussion but here's the rub
man and this is something I learned as a
therapist
conflict delayed is conflict multiplied
if you have a problem with you or with
your partner
then if you don't sort it out
then you're going to have that Bloody
problem for the rest of your life
and absolutely maybe it'll be a problem
that comes up every week so that's like
50 times a year and you're married for
30 years that's gonna you're gonna have
that problem 1500 times
1500 times and maybe it'll take an hour
per time
so that's 1500 hours and so that's 30
work weeks that's basically a year of
work of your life that's like two
percent of your life so then you think
well should I have a fight and the
answer is damn right right now man four
hours Let's hash this out right let's
figure out how we're stupid and then
let's figure out how we can not do this
again right and that we're both buy into
right because hey you have to both buy
into it it has to be voluntary but
you see so you have that fear of not
being right and you have the fear maybe
of having the fight and you have the
fear of discovering what's wrong with
you and fine those are all valid fears
but you need to balance that against the
fear of having the same fight 1500 times
yeah that's not good
yeah even even worse is just remaining
silent and never making that person
aware of of the the problem that you
have I mean what a disservice to whoever
you're in a relationship with to for
them to remain ignorant to something
that you are having such trouble with
it's just a really difficult thing to do
but it must be done yeah well you know
yeah it is kind of polite to
you know one of the things I often hear
people say couples used to say this to
each other because now and then I had
couples in my therapy session I was
always concentrating on a particular
individual but sometimes it was useful
to have their partner in you know people
would often say something when they were
talking to their partner like well if
you loved me you'd know what I wanted
it's like well sometimes that's true and
you're not just paying attention but you
know first of all you don't even know
what you want
so how the hell would you expect someone
else and to know and maybe you could be
polite enough to let them in on the
secret
you know that'd be kind of nice now you
have to make yourself vulnerable right
well here's the problem with that if you
let me know what you want and need
then I can manipulate you and I can deny
that to you right see if I don't know
what you want need then if I'm going to
torture you it's kind of Hit or Miss but
if you let me in on the secret then I
know where You're vulnerable and I can
really misuse that and so you have to
trust someone to let them know what you
want need you really have to trust them
and then you might say well that's naive
to trust like that but it's not unless
you're naive once you're past being
naive that sort of trust is courage not
naivety it's like I know you could hurt
me I know it
especially if I tell you this but I'm
going to do it anyways because that's an
invitation to the best in you
right and then maybe we could sort out
this problem and maybe you know you'll
have the same luxury with me you'll be
able to tell me something that you need
and want
and so that's the sort of trust you have
to have in a relationship in order for
it to progress properly
and if you don't I mean what is what is
your relationship who who is the person
dating if they don't know you if they
don't know your wants and needs I mean
so so often people reach out to me on
the political end of the spectrum and
say I'm so scared to come to my friends
and tell them that I agree with some of
the things that you say and I'm sure you
run into this a lot but to that you just
say well what friends are they if they
don't know you and they don't know how
you think and feel about certain things
and what are you truly giving people in
this relationship and what are they
getting from you in this relationship if
they don't know who you are
yeah well that's the thing you know if
you're in the grip of an ideology and
you're falsifying your own experience to
be an agent of that ideology then it's
the ideology that has your life and not
you
right and that's and that really is a
form of possession it's like you don't
get to say what you want to say you
don't get to feel what you need to feel
you the friends you have don't know who
you are they're not really your friends
they're allies they're ideological
allies they're really comrades you know
in some real sense yeah and it's a lot
better to have friends than comrades by
any stretch of the imagination
so absolutely
all right well we're out of time that
went by very quickly and so for everyone
who's listening I'm going to go over to
the Daily wire plus platform and talk to
amila some more on the more biographical
front and uh in the meantime I'd like to
thank all of you who are watching and
listening for doing exactly that and
hope you found especially young people
who might be listening
hope you found this uh discussion useful
in guiding you through the swamps of
your of your philosophical Journey
you know and and and I hope you found it
helpful in terms of helping you find the
courage to have your own voice and to
find your own friends and to make your
own way
you know in truth and to be very careful
about the pride that goes along with
ideological possession it's a very bad
thing it is definitely the cardinal sin
and so anyways thanks to all of you who
are watching and listening thanks I'm
alone it was good talking to you we'll
continue on The Daily wire plus platform
I'm going to ask Amela Bacha
biographical questions and delve a
little bit more into the dark secrets of
her past
thanks everyone
thank you thank you very much she yeah
yeah you bet you bet it's pleasure
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com